congratulations you have both made it
through the second round and are now one
round closer to the title of forged and
fire champion in a check for ten
thousand dollars now we're asking you to
forge a weapon whose Origins go back
thousands of years
the moro Chris
the Chris came into existence around
1361 A.D in the Kingdom of majapahit
East Java believed to be the primary
weapons wielded by Asian Warriors its
distinctive wavy blade creates a wider
wound during combat causing the victim
to quickly bleed to death the hilt is
viewed as a work of art and is often
carved in meticulous detail from
precious wood gold or Ivory in popular
culture the crisp can be seen in the
video game Mortal Kombat
good luck bladesmiths we will see you in
five days
my name is Murray Carter I'm a
bladesmith I've always been fascinated
with knives and martial weapons growing
up to Fuller or not to Fuller that
definitely is the question and I've
never done the fullering in Blaze before
even if I lose the competition I've
learned a new skill so my fear today is
that I won't get a perfect heat treat it
could get too hot in some places or not
hot enough in other places
it's kind of difficult in my little
Forge to heat up such a large blade it's
all done with the human senses so
anything can happen
I don't think it cracks just it just
bands up so it's got to be it's got to
be heated higher
damn it now I've got to go back and
punch it again
the second quench went okay I decided to
go with a multi-piece construction for
the handle that doesn't require any
drilling through the Tang which would
potentially weaken it
I know I've done my absolute best with
this project I'm all ready for this
competition
my name is Mace Vitale I run a
blacksmithing program at a local Arts
Center I'm also a stay-at-home dad part
of the week I plan on constructing a 23
layer fillet of Damascus to make the
sword from
seven layers for each of my competitors
and I'm there for my daughter I learned
from my wife my plan is to go to my
other shop and get it heat treated
damn
quenching seemed to go good I didn't
hear any Tings so hopefully we got a
good viable blade throughout my work
I've been trying to harness the spirit
of the tiger and put that in my sword
pointy Blade's gonna have some stripes
the handle's gonna have some Stripes
Tiger Claws a little tiger tooth
I'm gonna win
tigers are winners and I am the tiger
the unique design of a moral Chris has
even made more distinct by its fluid
wave-like edges it can thrust but its
primary purpose is slashing and chopping
to test your Chris's ability to perform
according to its ancient design I will
use it to chop and slice against these
moving targets base here up first are
you ready sure
thank you
nice
nice balance nice recovery allows you to
just move with a blade
good job thank you Mary you're next you
ready certainly am
[Music]
well Marie the balance of this blade
allows me to Chase an attack and will
come with me on the recovery to go to
another attack it will stay with me it
doesn't go away from me
it'll slice good job thank you
Tessa lethality of your Chris I will
take your weapon I'm going to strike
into this animal carcass mace you're up
first you ready yes sir
well it cut cleanly through the spine
all the way through the meat in one big
sweeping slash it will kill
good job thank you very much where are
you up next you ready yep
when cutting through there was a slight
drag in the feel of the cut but it did
cut very cleanly through it's a very
very sharp blade
they will kill
bamboo is a very durable material
ounce for ounce it is stronger than
concrete brick or wood to test the
strength of your crisp I will deliver
four strikes into the bamboo to see how
well your weapon stands up mace you're
up
foreign
no damage to the blade sir it chopped
nicely but a couple of times over there
it didn't want to fall out of my hand
just because it's so heavy on the blade
but nonetheless looks like your Edge did
hold up where are you up you ready
yes I am
okay Murray looks like your blade Edge
held up with the chops it almost clearly
sliced all the way through
but there is now an issue that we're
looking at with your blade I think there
might be a little Bend here caused from
chopping into the bamboo
but other than that
still has a very sharp edge the strength
of the blade held up
good job thank you
I'm pleased with the performance of my
blade but I think Murray's blade did
well too and I think it's going to be a
tough decision for the judges
gentlemen both of you have been
outstanding competitors through three
rounds of competition in five days you
have fabricated fully functioning moral
crisis that you should both be proud of
but there can only be one champion
mace
you are the forged Empire Champion yes
congratulations thank you Marissa thanks
very much Murray unfortunately your
Chris did not make the cut
Murray I find that weapon absolutely
beautiful and comfortable but the fact
that there's a soft core in there
somewhere and that it picked up a Bend
where your opponent's blade did not that
was the deciding factor and that's why
we had to let you go
Murray please surrender your weapon
while there's always a disappointment
when one puts their best effort forward
and doesn't win thank you gentlemen
thank you I do feel an overwhelming
sense of gratitude for having been able
to participate mace made the better
blade and I'm proud of them
mace congratulations
nice fantastic I mean the Steel's
beautiful I like how you did the file
work on the blade blade held up
beautifully The Edge is razor sharp to
be exceptionally proud of that piece and
a great job I'm the forge and fire
Champion I feel good and I'm glad it
came out on top I'm the Tiger